INTRO:
The 2008 financial crisis was devastating, but the
silver lining is that it shed light onto some of
the biggest frauds and shortfalls of the industry.
Of course, many of the largest players faced no
consequences, but most mid-sized perpetrators
got obliterated. One of these perpetrators was a
hedge fund named Absolute Capital Management run
by Florian Homm. Up until 2008, Absolute Capital
Management or ACM was one of the fastest growing
hedge funds in the world and Florian was regarded
as an investing genius. The fund managed roughly
$3 billion at their peak and they were crushing
the S&P 500 year after year. But in late 2007,
Florian could sense that a storm was coming
and that his facade was about to crumble.
So, he stuffed $500,000 into his underwear and
disappeared off the face of the planet. ACM
subsequently crashed 93% by June of 2008 and the
SEC would charge Florian with $200 million worth
of investment fraud. Since then, Florian has been
on the FBI’s most wanted list, but to this day,
the FBI hasn’t been able to serve him justice.
And it’s not like they don’t know where he is
either. Everyone knows that he’s living in
Germany and he even does interviews to this
day claiming his innocence. But despite this, the
FBI has been able to do nothing. So, here’s the
story of how Florian Homm stole $200 million and
successfully escaped the FBI’s most wanted list.
FLORIAN HOMM:
Taking a look back, Florian was born on
October 7, 1959 in a small town near Frankfurt,
Germany called Oberursel. Growing up, Florian
had a pretty nice childhood as his father was
a rather successful businessman. Florian’s father
had built up a pipe welding and bathroom fittings
installation business that was quite lucrative.
Though Florian was grateful for the business,
he had no interest in following his father
into the business. To Florian, welding pipes
and installing bathroom fixtures sounded extremely
boring. Something that did interest him though was
his great uncle Josef Neckermann. Josef was not
only filthy rich, but he was a superstar. Josef
was an equestrian olympic athlete who had won 2
gold medals, 2 silver medals, and 2 bronze medals.
He also won two world championships and 4 European
championships. And on top of all this, Josef
started Germany’s largest mail order business
at the time and employed 30,000 employees.
So, if Josef were alive today, he would basically
be a billionaire olympian. Josef hosted a family
gathering at his mansion every Sunday, and Florian
recalls that these visits are what convinced
Florian that he had to be rich just like his
great uncle. And with that in mind, Florian would
be sent off to the US where he attended Bentley
High School in Michigan. Florian ended up crushing
high school and would be accepted into Harvard
university where he got a bachelors and an MBA.
And following his studies, Florian scored a job
at the prestigious Merrill Lynch. He worked here
for a couple of years, but he would eventually
switch over to Fidelity Investments where he got
the opportunity to work under and be personally
trained by Peter Lynch. After leveraging this
phenomenal opportunity, Florian moved back to
Germany where he would become a senior vice
president at Julius Bar. I think most of us would
agree that Florian was already killing it, but his
ambitions were much larger, so Florian would
go ahead and start his first company in 1993.
GOOD TIMES:
Florian’s first company was called Value
Management & Research and it was based in
Frankfurt Germany. At first glance, the company
is just another run of the mill hedge fund,
but Florian’s charm is what would
really attract investors. You see,
Florian had a very peculiar investing philosophy.
He believed that the traditional hedge funds were
doing it all wrong with their fancy algorithms and
complex mathematics. Florian believed that it was
much better to approach investing holistically.
For example, instead of basing your investments
on quarterly reports, with holistic investing,
you would base your investments on the impact
and influence of the company. This isn’t exactly
a new idea as long term investors often tend to be
more holistic anyway, but for a hedge fund, this
was definitely out of the ordinary. Florian chose
a couple of internet and technology hype stocks
to invest in, and thanks to the dotcom bubble,
these stocks would explode. Florian became iconic
for these investments and these stocks were often
referred to as Homm stocks. Moving past the dotcom
bubble, Florian began to spend his new found
fortune. In 2004, for instance, he invested 20
million euros into the German soccer club Borussia
Dortmund. The soccer team was nearly bankrupt
and was suffering from terrible management.
So, when Florian invested 20 million and overthrew
the old management, he was hailed as a hero
by many soccer fans. Florian would leverage this
media attention to start a new hedge fund in 2005,
and that brings us to the infamous Absolute
Capital Management. ACM was launched to great
fanfare and given Florian’s popularity,
charm, and holistic investment strategy,
investors flooded in. ACM did have quite a few
winning picks, but they were all quite odd.
Florian wasn’t investing into Apple or Amazon.
One of his most famous investments was actually
a Berlin brothel called Artemis. Such weird
choices simply garnered ACM even more attention,
and Alternative Investment News would even name
ACM as the hedge fund leader of the year. By 2007,
ACM had grown to $3 billion in assets, and
Florian’s personal fortune was worth $700 million.
But it wasn’t all good as Florian’s great
wealth also attracted negative attention.
FAILED ASSASSINATION:
One day in 2006, as Florian was traveling
through the streets of Caracas, Venezuela,
he would be stopped by a group of armed men.
The armed men demanded everything Florian had
on him which included his wallet, mobile phone,
and watch. Florian quickly handed over his
wallet and phone, but he didn’t want to part
with his watch. When Florian tried negotiating
to keep his watch though, the armed men started
shooting. Florian was shot in his chest and ended
up losing most of his left lung and his spleen.
But thanks to emergency surgery, Florian was able
to survive. While it seems like this was simply a
robbery that went bad, Florian is convinced that
this was an assassination attempt, and there
is good reason to believe this. First of all,
Florian wasn’t traveling alone, he was traveling
with his bodyguard and driver. Not only did the
bodyguard do a poor job at protecting Florian,
but he was shot in a much more non lethal way.
The bodyguard was shot in the knee and the driver
wasn’t shot at all. So, it’s possible that the
bodyguard and/or driver were working with the
robbers. Something else to consider is that, in
most cases, robbers aren’t looking to hurt you.
They simply want your money, and being wanted
for homicide is much more risky than being
wanted for a robbery. So, it’s odd that the
robbers were so willing to open fire, especially
in a lethal way. Despite the sketchiness of
the situation, it was never determined if this
really was a failed assasination attempt or simply
idiot robbers. This experience did, however, lead
to Florian reevaluating his life choices. Florian
says that he had all the money he could ever need,
but he was wasting his life working 16 hours a day
6 days a week. He could afford all the luxuries he
wanted, but he didn’t have the time to actually
enjoy them. So, in September of 2007, Florian
announced that he would be selling his stake in
ACM and retiring. This was a bit of a douchebag
move, as his $40 million stock sale crashed the
stock 75% from $2 billion to $500 million. Anyway,
after the sale, Florian would spread this money
across 120 bank accounts located in 4 different
continents, and he would flee the US. On his
flight out of the US, Florian carried $500,000 in
his underwear and his accomplice carried another
$700,000. This was no doubt a pretty sketchy
way to leave, but many were still sympathetic
towards Florian given his near death experience.
In reality though, Florian had just gotten away
with one of the biggest frauds in US history.
THE FACADE:
Despite all of the positive press Florian was
receiving, his entire fund was basically a scam.
He was literally operating fraud on top of fraud
on top of fraud, and the SEC was catching on.
The first form of fraud Florian was running was
the classic penny stock pump and dump. Between
2004 and 2006, Florian had been using his massive
cash reserves to buy up low volume penny stocks,
and dump them onto uneducated investors. Aside
from running a pump and dump, Florian had a
clever way to make even more money on the side.
You see, Florian had set up a secondary company
that was responsible for executing trades for ACM,
and this company charged insanely high fees. So,
not only was Florian making money on the pump and
dump itself, but he was making money executing
trades for the pump and dumps. Not all of
ACM’s investments were in pump and dumps,
but even the non pump and dumps had fraud
written all over them. For example, Florian
and his partners would regularly trade stocks
amongst themselves to inflate the daily volume of
these stocks and make it seem like these stocks
were way more popular than they really were.
ACM also had investments in private companies and
given that these shares weren’t traded publicly,
it was ACM’s job to provide their investors with
a fair valuation for these private companies.
But as you would guess, the valuations that
ACM told their investors were way inflated.
Looking back, there were a bunch of red flags
surrounding ACM from the very beginning.
ACM was posting insane growth numbers during a
relatively stagnant time following the dotcom
crash. Not to mention, ACM was registered in the
Cayman islands. Anyway, the SEC did eventually
catch on and the FBI would file criminal
charges against Florian in March of 2013.
But, Florian had already lived a free life for 6
years and he had no intention of changing that.
ESCAPING THE FBI:
Florian wasn’t able to just walk away from the FBI
though. Just two days after the FBI filed criminal
charges, they were able to locate Florian in Italy
and arrest him. From the very beginning, it seemed
like Florian's plan was to just battle against
extradition. His lawyers argued that Florian
suffered from multiple sclerosis and that he
couldn’t be extradited due to health concerns. The
FBI played along and fought back against Florian’s
lawyers with doctors that testified that Florian’s
condition did not prevent incarceration. It seemed
like the FBI was winning as the court would side
with the FBI and agree to extradite Florian which
meant up to a 225 year long prison sentence.
While the FBI was celebrating, Florian had
a completely different plan to get out.
You see, Italy actually has a rule that once an
extradition decision becomes final, the prisoner
must be extradited within 45 days or they’re
released from prison. It’s not clear if stalling
was a 200 IQ move from Florian or if it was
simply an oversight from the FBI. But either way,
Florian would be released from prison on June 23,
2014. As soon as Florian was released, he bought
a train ticket to Florence where his lawyers
picked him up and took him to Germany. Florian
crossed the German border the following day,
and this officially marked his freedom. You see,
Germany has a strict policy of not extraditing
German citizens, and since the German courts don’t
have any arrest warrants against Florian, Florian
is a free man as long as he stays in Germany.
LIFE AS A FREE-ISH MAN:
Florian is still on the FBI’s most wanted
list, but the FBI has avoided extraditing
him by force because they don’t
want to ruin relations with Germany.
In the meantime, Florian has become a completely
different man. He says that his year in Italian
prison completely changed his outlook on life.
He’s transparent that what he did at ACM was
completely immoral and unethical, but he still
holds that he didn’t break any laws. Florian has
become a strong christian and spends most of his
time sharing his knowledge and donating his money.
For example, he published a book called Rogue
Financier, and he donated 100% of the profits
to the Liberia Renaissance Foundation. He also
co-founded a charity called Our Lady’s Message of
Mercy to the World Foundation. He even has his own
YouTube channel where he discusses his thoughts on
the world, the economy, and the stock market on a
regular basis. So, Florian has turned into more of
a Wolf of Wall Street type figure as opposed to
a Bernie Madoff type figure. Still, some people
argue that Florian should be extradited to the US
and jailed for his crimes while others argue that
what Florian is doing now is a much better way
to repay society instead of just rotting in jail.
Which camp are you in? Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re glad that Florian
is at least changing his ways. And of course,
consider joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.